[Musique]
récemment soit sans doute entendu parler
d'un vaccin contre la coved 19
tu te demandes peut-être comment tout ça
fonctionne et surtout s'il faut s'en
méfie radio-canada a préparé cette
petite vidéo pour d'éclairer sur la
question le vaccin a été inventé il y à
135 ans par un scientifique qui
s'appelait louis pasteur
le vaccin c'est quand tu vas chez le
médecin pour recevoir une piqûre par
exemple il sert à te protéger contre des
maladies dangereuses et contagieuse
le vaccin est un liquide qu'on injecte
dans ton corps à l'aide d'une seringue
il peut aussi être administré par la
bouche ou encore par le nez dans ce
liquide
il y a une petite quantité de bactéries
et de virus mais ne t'inquiète pas ces
microbes sont affaiblis ils sont
inoffensifs
quand les microbes affaibli sont
injectés dans ton corps il se passe une
chose fascinante une petite armée
d'anticorps s'activent pour les
combattre et lille neutralisé
comme dans un match de boxe l'armée
d'anticorps mais les microbes carreau
c'est ce qu'on appelle le système
immunitaire
une fois réveillé cette armée demeure
très alerte elle garde en mémoire qui
est son ennemi à chaque fois qu'elle
aperçoit un microbe elle se met en mode
attaque les anticorps savent quelle arme
utilisée pour empêcher les microbes de
te rendent malade
la bonne nouvelle c'est que ces
anticorps d'honneur avec toi pour la vie
plus il ya de gens vaccinés plus l'armée
grandit et devient forte un point tel
que les microbes finissent par ne plus
savoir où aller
et donc ils se font moins présent par
contre si on arrêtait de vacciner tout
le monde
l'indic robe reviendrai
dans le cas de la coved 19 grâce aux
vaccins ton armée personnelle
d'anticorps guette le corona virus les
soldats sont prêts à le détruire avant
qu'il ne te rendent malades de la coved